Merhaba değerli dostum meschemy kimya
kanalına Hoş Geldin 9 sınıf kimya yeni
müfredatla karşındayım Milli Eğitim
kitabımızda belli şeyler var orada
etkinlikler var ama detayları anlatmak
lazım diye düşünüyorum o yüzden bu
derste sana orada olmayıp da bilmen
gereken bazı detayları Vereceğim 8
sınıftaki bazı kısımları ufak bir
şekilde tekrar etmiş olacağız Yani seni
Yeni müfredata ciddi bir şekilde
hazırlayacağım dostum kitabın ücretsiz
pdf'i açıklama kısmına bırakıyorum
Oradan girip indirebilirsin dostum Peki
bugün hangi bölümü göreceğiz kitapta onu
göstereyim Evet işte bugün Şurayı
işleyeceğiz günlük hayatta kimya
dediğimiz kısımdan bahsedeceğiz bakalım
detayları neymiş istersen vakit
kaybetmeyelim başlayalım geldik
kitabımıza işte kitapta bak günlük
yaşamda kimya dediğimiz bir kısımla
başlıyoruz kimya hayattır kısmıyla
başlıyoruz günlük hayatta birçok madde
vardır ve bunlar hep Kimya ile ilgilidir
şöyle söyleyeyim neler vardır günlük
hayatta hangi maddeler kimyayla çok
ilgilidir temizlik maddeleri Mesela
kimyacıların en çok uğraştığı alanlardan
bir tanesidir Gıda ve ilaç dediğimiz
Yani bu hazır gıdalar ilaçlar mesela
yediğin ne dondurma bir sürü kimyasal
madde var içerisinde başka kola da örnek
veriyorum Bunları Hani günlük hayattan
örnekler veriyorum bunların içerisinde
bir sürü kimyasal madde var bozulmasını
engelleyici renk verici şu bu birçok şey
vardır kimya burada ciddi bir şekilde ne
yapmakta ortaya çıkmakta Yani bunların
oluşumunda kimya ve kimyacılar çok
önemli yer tutmakta başka ne var işte
enerji üretiminde yine kimyacılar çok
etkilidir bilgisayar bilgisayarların
işlenmesi Yani şöyle söyleyeyim sana
bilgisayarla kimyanın Ne ilgisi var
diyebilirsin silikon teknolojisi var
değil mi Çipler Çipler silikondan
silisyum içermektedir Daha doğrusu bu
çipleri yapan kişiler yine nedir
kimyacılarda Yani kimyacıların büyük bir
katkısı vardır burada telefonların şarj
olmasında kimyanın Ne ilgisi var
diyebilirsin o piller nedir bataryalar e
bildiğin kimyacıların yaptığı şeylerdir
içerisinde neler var lityum iyon piller
diyoruz nikel kadmiyum piller diyoruz
işte bu pillerin oluşumunda kimya ve
kimyacılar etkilidir televizyon
ekranının parlaması hocam Ne alaka ya
buradaki işte O televizyon ekranının
oluşturulmasında da kimya Çok etkili bir
yerdedir Başka ne söyleyebiliriz Mesela
işte günlük hayatta  yeme içme
ihtiyaçlarımız da temizlik
ihtiyaçlarımız da hepsinde kimya baş
roldedir diyebilirim şimdi Kimya
biliminin derinliklerine gideceğiz de
şöyle bak Bir tane örneğimiz var burada
diyor ki Yukarıdaki sorunlardan
hangilerinin cevabı kimya bilimi ile
ilgili herhangi bir kaynakta bulunabilir
diyor ki çamaşır suyunun içinde hangi
madde var sodyum hipoklorit nacl
dediğimiz madde ağırtıcı bir maddedir
dezenfektanda burada bulabiliriz
birincisi var Hatta şöyle işaretleyelim
bu var diyor ki teflon tavalara konan
yiyecekler neden tavaya yapışmaz Çünkü
orada teflon dediğimiz bir madde var
teflon neydi C2 F4 dediğimiz bir bileşik
mesela E bu madde teflon dediğimiz madde
bir polimer maddeyi bu kimyanın etkili
olduğu şeylerden bir tanesidir polimer
kimyası vardır mesela o zaman bunun da
cevabını bulabiliriz doğalgaz gaz
halinde çıkar doğalgaz gaz halinde
çıkarıldığı halde neden sıvı halde
taşınır Bu da işte gazlar
sıvılaştırılır bu şekilde taşınabilir
bunu da kimya kitaplarında ve Kimya ile
ilgili kaynaklarda bulabileceğim bir
şeydir Bu da vardır yani cevap Ne oldu e
seçeneği oldu dedim ya kimya bilimi
insan hayatının her yerinde var mesela
nerelerde var işte el yüz temizliğinde
kullanıyoruz sabunlarda var mesela kimya
çok etkilidir başka ilaçlarda
hastalıkların tedavisinde tanısında
şunda bunda ilaçlar yine nedir işte
Kimya biliminin etkili olduğu yerlerden
bir tanesidir söylemiştim Az önce çip
teknolojisi bu silikon çiplerde yine
nedir kimya etkilidir çevre kirliliğinin
önlenmesinde de etkilidir Hatta bu
çevreye zarar veren maddeler vardır
nedir plastik atıklar E bu da
kimyacıların ürettiği Daha doğrusu Kimya
biliminin etkili olduğu yerlerden bir
tanesidir polimer kimyası ve bunun
çözümü de yine nedir kimyanın
içerisindedir bunu söyleyebiliriz dostum
Peki bak günlük hayattan bazı şeyler var
maddeler var çok gördüğümüz maddeler var
bunların acaba nerelerde kullanıldığına
dair günlük hayatta nerelerde
kullanıldığına dair bir işaretleme
yapabilir miyiz gel istersen yapalım
Burada çamaşır suyu çamaşır suyu neydi
evde çok kullanılıyordu değil mi
nerelerde kullanıyorsun Bir düşün
çamaşırda falan K bak adı üstünde
çamaşır suyu ağartmada falan
kullanılıyordu o zaman genel Temizlikte
var mıdır Bence vardır buraya işareti
koyduk Başka ne var mesela
dezenfektanda kullanılıyor Onun dışında
ilaç ı öz bakım vücuduna falan
sürebiliyor musun yok yiyecek içecek II
mümkün değil kireç çözücü değildir
kireçler baziktir çamaşır suyu da bazik
olduğu için bu burada kullanılmaz Tamam
Bu ikisini
işaretledikten de şurada burada
kullanılıyorsa ne yapıyoruz diş macunu
adı üstünde Öz bakımımızda kullanıyoruz
buraya işareti koyduk limon tuzu bak
limon tuzu çok geniş bir kullanım
alanına sahiptir mesela nerelerde
kullanılıyor kireç çözücü olarak
kullanılıyor Çünkü limon tuzu asidik bir
madde ekşi ya ekşiler asidik e neydi
kireç çözücü kireç de bazik o zaman
kireci çözmek için kullanabilirim genel
Temizlikte kullanılmaktadır Onun dışında
yiyecek içeceklerde kullanılmakta Mesela
ben evde limonata yaptığımda az biraz
böyle şey koyarım limon tuzu koyarım ki
O ekşiliğini sağlasın mesela yiyecek
içeceklerde de kullanılmakta Senin
birçok gıd anda Yani yediğin gıdada da
bulunmakta sitrik asit olarak
kullanılmakta bu sıvı sabuna bakarsak
mesela sıvı sabun nerelerde kullanılıyor
dezenfektan olarak kullanılabiliyor
Başka neydi ha Başlığa bakarak
söyleyeyim genel Temizlikte
kullanılabiliyor E başka nerede
vücudumuzu temizlemek için de kullanılır
yani Öz bakımda da ne yapılır kullanılır
Gazlı içecekler var Gazlı içecekler
nerelerde kullanılır bir kere yiyecek
içecek neredeydi la He yiyecek içecek 4C
sıradayım burada var peki gazlı içecek
asidik değil mi asidik o zaman kireç
çözebilir mi yani Kireçli bir yeri kola
dökerek temizleyebilir miyiz ya ihtimal
olabilir Neredeydi o kireç çözücü ikinci
sıradaydı Heh onu da
işaretledikten falan kullanılan bir
şeydir temizlikler neredeydi He 3üncü
sıradaydı o zaman şuraya işaretledikten
II kireç çözücü kireç bazik de bu da
bazik olmaz e yiyecek içecek de Hayır
canım ilaç olarak Hayır kullanmıyoruz Öz
bakımda kullanmıyoruz geldik sirkeye He
sirke sirke mesela nerelerde
kullanılıyor bir kere dezenfektan olarak
kullanılıyor Çünkü iyi bir dezenfekte
edici maddedir başka asidik olduğu için
kireç çözücü olarak kullanılı mesela
çaydanlık kireçlendi yinde içerisine
sirke döküp kaynatırsan temizlemiş
olursun Başka ne söyleyebiliriz 3ün
sıradaki neydi la Heh genel temizlik
Evet sirke evde temizlik maddesi olarak
kullanırlar ki hatta sağlıklı temizlik
maddesi olarak söylenir başka ne var
Evet yiyecek içeceklerde de
kullanılmakta hatta bak şurada benim
elimin altında şurada bir tane Sirke var
şöyle göstereyim sana İşte bu sirke Eee
çok da güzel bir sirke Birazdan da
tadına bakacağım zaten bu yiyecek
içeceklerde salatalarda falan ne
yapıyoruz kullanıyoruz şimdi Milli
Eğitim kitabında da buna benzer bir
etkinlik vardı oradaki etkinliği de
mesela bu şekilde doldurabilirsin Dostum
şimdi gelelim bu maddelerle ilgili şunu
diyebilirsin sen ya hocam ben bu
maddeleri az çok ismini duydum ama
özelliklerini bilmiyorum diyebilirsin
şimdi gel o özelliklerden bahsedelim
Mesela ne vardı Elimizin altında çamaşır
suyu vardı değil mi Şöyle Azıcık da
yaklaşalım He çamaşır suyu dediğimiz şey
bazik bir maddeye sahiptir ağırtıcı
özelliği vardır aşındırıcı özelliğe
sahiptir dezenfektan naclo formülüyle
gösterilir bazik bir maddedir Hım bak
asitlere bazlara da gireceğim Başka
lavabo açıcı dedik sodyum hidroksit
bazik bir madde olduğunu söylemiştik süt
kostik olarak bilinmektedir aşındırıcı
ve yakıncı etkiye sahiptir yani yani
vücuda gelirse tehlikeli bir maddedir
onu söyleyeyim o yüzden lavabo açılması
işleminde döktün ya onu sıcak suyu
döktüğünde şöyle eğilip bakma diyor Mal
gibi bakma Orada diyor yüzüne gelir
diyor çok tehlikeli diyor yakıcı
aşındırıcı etkisi bulunmakta başka
temizlik amacıyla kullanılan mesela tuz
ruhu vardır tuz ruhu dediğimiz asidik
hcl dediğimiz midemizde de bulunan bir
asit maddesi Bu da aşındırıcı bir
maddedir mesela kola ve gazlı
içeceklerde karbonik asit bulunur ki
karbondioksit gazı çıkarıyor ya sebebi
budur asidik bir maddedir H2 co3 böyle
gösterilir E başka ne var işte sıvı sa
dediğimiz sıvı sabunda c17 h35 coook
dediğimiz bir madde bulunmakta bazik bir
madde ele kayganlık hissi verdiği için
ciltte kayganlık hissi oluşturuyorsa
bazik bir madde olarak söyleyebiliriz
Burada da onu söylüyor işte bu yani c17
h35 coo k yani sabun bazik Bunu bil
yeter sonra limon tuzu dedik Değil mi
limon tuzu asidik Bir maddeyi sitrik
asit dediğimiz madde formülü de neymiş
C6 h8 o7 formülü bilmek zorunda mısın ya
Tabii ki bilmek zorunda değilsin yani
limon tuzu asidik Bunu bil yeter Mesela
ve kireç Dericiler olarak kullanılan
sirke vardı değil mi sirke
ch3cooh dediğimiz asetik asit yani
asidik bir maddedir kireçler baziktir
kireç bazik olduğu için ne yaparız limon
tuzu ya da sirkeyle oradaki kireci
giderebiliriz işte Evdeki Çaydanlıkları
temizlerken dedim ya ya sirke ya da
limon tuzu kullanabiliyorsun Peki onun
tepkimesi nasıl bir şey onu şurada
göstereyim bak aşağıda yazmışım Ne bu
kireç dediğimiz Kalsiyum karbonat bazik
bir madde sirke asidik bir madde Bu
ikisini karıştırdım bir tepkime
gerçekleşti bu tep tepkime sonucunda
orada böyle bir kabarcıklar oluşuyor ya
o kabarcığın sebebi işte karbondioksit
gazı oluşması bu tepkimede böyle bir
durum söz konusu bu Kireçli maddeler
kireç taşı içeren maddeler zaten
Asitlerle tepkimeye girince böyle bir
karbondioksit gazı oluşturma durumu söz
konusu Başka ne söyleyebiliriz işte
asidik maddeler bazik maddelerle ne
yapar tepkimeye girmekte günlük hayatta
da bol miktarda kullanıyoruz bunları
Tabii evimizde de bir sürü kimyasal
madde var işte Çamaşır suyu var başka
tuz ruhu yani var Bu da asidik bir madde
başka ne var bu lavabo açıcılar var
tuvalet açıcılar var mesela o daha
farklıdır sülfürik asit falan içerir çok
tehlikelidir Yani bunlar aşındırıcı
maddelerdir kireç kireç gidericiler de
aynı şekilde aşındırıcı dır çok
tehlikelidir dezenfektan etkiye sahip
olanlar var ki işte Çamaşır suyu Es kaza
içersen çok tehlikeli bir şeydir
zehirlenebilir yani evlerdeki
kimyasalları tanıman gerekiyor dostum
üzerindeki işaretlerle ilgili de zaten
konuşacağım Mesela işte evlerde mutfak
gereçlerinde banyolarda şurada burada
kireç oluşuyor ya Bak şöyle kireç
oluşuyor Bu kireci ne yapabilirsin İşte
sirkeyle temizleyebilirsiniz
şeyde Instagram'da şurada burada da
görmüşsündür büyük ihtimale böyle duş
başlığı kireç uçları kireç bağlamış
diyor ki bunu al diyor poşetin içerisine
sirke doldur diyor duş başlığını da
içine sok ondan sonra ağzını bağla bir
bir saat ik saat beklesin sonra
açtığında tertemiz olduğunu göreceksin
doğru söylüyor Çok doğru söylüyor
plastik olanlarda bunu uygulayabilirsin
ama metal olanlarda Bunu uygularsan o
metale de zarar verirsin çünkü ne metal
ile asit tepkimeye girer mi girer değil
mi Ama Metal olmayanlarda Plastik
olanlarda bunu kullanabilir misin Evet
kullanabilirsin ve o kireci çözer çok da
güzel açar devam edelim mesela midem
yanıyor derim değil mi Öf şimdi çok
yanıyor ne yapacağım ne yapacağım böyle
bir tane hap atarlar beyaz bir hap
vardır çiğneme tablet derler Onu
yedikten sonra Oh dersin midem rahatladı
veya işte çeşitli içecekler Karbonatlı
su içerler falan böyle niye rahatlatıyor
veya niye miden yanıyor onu söyleyeyim
mide yanması dediğimiz şey Midedeki
asidin artması midende çok fazla asit
varsa ne yapacaksın Bunu nötrleştirme
lazım bir şeyle tepkimeye sokman lazım
bazik bir şey lazım işte bu da ne
biliyor musun O şeyler antiasit
tabletleri magnezyum hidroksit içermekte
Bak tepkimede burada yazıyor midede asit
var hcl dediğimiz asit e antiasit
tabletlerinde de magnezyum hidroksit var
bir attın hop tepkime gerçekleşti hop
mide rahatladı pH böyle belli bir
seviyeye geldi rahatladı Ha bu arada
ondan da bahsedeceğim birazdan
söyleyeceğim asidik ortamda pH çok
düşüktür bunu işte ne yaparsın mide
yanması oldu ya pH çok düşük bazik bir
madde ekledim pH'ı yukarıya doğru çektin
mideyi rahatlatmış oldun Burada da bunu
gösteriyor işte aşırı asit
salgılandığında rahatlatmanın yolu bu
antiasit tabletleri olabilir mesela
günlük hayatta şöyle çiftçilerin de
kullandığı bir yöntem vardır Eğer
tarladaki Toprak çok asidik ve dikeceğim
madde de asidik Daha doğrusu dikeceğim
bitki de o asidik ortama uyum
sağlayamayacak saa toprağa mesela kireç
atarlar niye kireç bazik ya E Toprak
fazla asidik kirece attığında ne oluyor
işte orada ph'ını ayarlamış oluyor o
bitkinin orada rahat yetişmesini
sağlıyor yani tarlalara kireç atılması
bu kireç taşı ya da Sönmemiş kireç Neyse
ve odun külü aynı şey bunlar bazik
maddeler bunları attığında ne yapıyor
işte toprağın ph'ını ayarlamış oluyorsun
veya zeytinyağı üretiminde zeytinyağı
üretiminde bir şeyin zeytinyağının bir
asitliğinin olması gerekiyor 0 8 2 arası
falan diye bir şeyden bahsedilir asit
derecesinin bunu sağlamak için mesela
Eğer çok asidik sodyum hidroksit falan
kullanarak ne yapıyorlar bunu
ayarlıyorlar sodyum hidroksit orada
bazik madde e diğeri de asidik madde
Bunlar birbirini işte ne yapmış oluyor
dengelemiş oluyor veya işte Asitli
gıdalar tükettin meyve yedin şu bu Neyse
artık Sonrasında da ne yaparsın gider
dişlerini
fırçalarsak Çünkü diş minesinde de bazik
bir madde var Bunu rahatlatmanın nasıl
rahatlatacak diş macunuyla fırçalı musun
İşte diş macunu bazik Dişlerdeki o
asidik maddeleri ne yapmış oluyorsun
götürmüş oluyorsun Hatta ve hatta şunu
da tavsiye mi etsem dene mi desem
bilemedim de dişlerini fırçala dişlerini
fırçalık sonra bir parça limon ye ama
sonra bana küfür etme ha çok kötü bir
tat bırakır Neden Çünkü dişlerini
fırçaladıktan sonra ağzım bazik bir
ortama dönüştü limon da asidik ağızda
böyle bir tepkime oluyor çok da garip
bir tat bırakıyor şimdi deminden beri
söyledim ya asitler bazlar falan bunu
8de görmüştün istersen bir daha
hatırlayalım Tanecikli yapı maddenin
tanecikli yapısı ünitesi vardı orada
görmüştün asitlerin ve bazların
özelliklerini bir hatırlayalım bakalım
neydi genel olarak asitler suya işte
hidrojen veren maddelerde bazlar suya Oh
veren maddelerde e günlük hayattaki
birçok çok maddenin yani Gıda maddesinin
Tamam tadına bakıyorsun bunun asidik mi
bazik mi olduğunu anlayabiliyorsun nasıl
anlıyorsun tadına Bakabildin maddelerin
asidik mi bazik mi olduğunu
anlayabiliyorsun mesela limon tuzu değil
mi asidik diyoruz neden yediğin anda
ekşilik veriyor veya limon ekşilik
veriyor ekşilik verenler kimdi asitleri
mesela ama gidip sülfürik asiin tadına
bakamıyorsun değil mi Bakabildin
maddeler için söylüyorum bunu veya işte
bazik bir madde olarak neyi örnek
vereyim acı biber değil mi ağızda böyle
ciddi bir acılık bırakıyor Demek ki
bunda baz var kaps isin dediğimiz bir
madde Mesela yani buradan da şu yorumu
yapabiliyorsun diyorsun ki ha tadı ekşi
olan meyvelerde asit var Bak bu yorumu
hemen yapabiliyorsun Ama tabii ki tadına
bakabildim için buradaki asitler zayıf
asitler daha yani kuvvetli asiin tadına
pek bakabileceğin zannetmiyorum mesela
sülfürik asit D dil düştü yani kötü bir
şey değil mi yani zayıf asitlerin tadına
bakabiliyoruz O da hepsinin değil yani
bir kısmının O da meyvelerdeki falan
asitler işte günlük hayattan örnek
vermemiz gerekirse mesela Elmada ne
vardır ik asit vardır elmalik asit bak
kodlaması bu elmalik asit neyde Limon
tuzunda sitrik asit bulunmaktadır limon
veya işte Limonda sitrik asit
bulunmaktadır zaten ana maddesi o
sirkede mesela asitik asit bulunmakta
sirke asidi diyoruz o da ekşidir buradan
bunların asit olduğunu zaten
anlayabiliyorsun veya Çilek asit çilekte
ne vardır Çilek folik bak Çilek Folik
birbirine benziyor folik asit bulunmakta
üzümü nasıl alırsın tartarak alırsın
değil mi İşte üzümde tartarik asit
bulunmakta buradan kodla tamam mı üzüm
tartarik asit zeytinyağında mesela oleik
asit bulunmakta zeytinyağı veya yağ
dediğimiz neydi Oil diye yazılıyor değil
mi Oil diye yazılıyor Bak oleik asit Oil
oradan aklında kalsın tamam mı neydi
asitlerin özellikleri bir hatırlayalım
bakalım tatları ekşiydi sulu çözeltisine
hidrojen veriyorlardı suda
çözündüklerinde az ya da çok
iyonlaştırıcı iletiyorlar ki biz buna
elektrolit çözelti ifadesini
kullanıyoruz mavi turnusolu kırmızıya
çeviriyordu kırmızı turnus soluna
rengini değiştirmiyorsa
girdiğinde tuz oluşturuyorlardı
aşındırıcı özelliğe sahiptiler ve cilde
temasında aşındırıcı yakıcı tahriş edici
yakıcı etkiye sahiptirler onu
söyleyebiliriz ve karbonatlı
bileşiklerle karbonat içeren
bileşiklerle tepkimeye girdiklerinde
karbondioksit gazı oluşturur ki işte o
kireç taşını Daha doğrusu kireçlenmiş
bir çaydanlığa limon tuzu veya işte
sirke döktüğümüzde kabarcık çıkmasının
sebebi bu işte ve bazı metallerle
tepkimeye girerek ki bunlara aktif
metaller diyoruz tepkimeye girdiğinde
tuz ve Hidrojen gazı oluşur yani gazı
oluşturuyor Hidrojen gazı
oluşturabiliyor bunu da ek bilgi olarak
söylüyorum Şu an zaten hani öyle detaylı
bilmene gerek yok bazlara Hani günlük
hayatta baz dediğimizde aklımıza ne
geliyor acıbiber geliyor Hardal geliyor
değil mi bunların içerisinde baz
bulunmakta mesela veya işte yine günlük
hayattan kireç taşı Sönmemiş kireç yani
Kireçli maddeler sönmüş kireç Kireçli
maddeler baziktir sonra Çamaşır sodası
çamaşır suyu yemek sodası karbonatlı dır
onlarda mesela Yemek sodasının diğer
ismi mesela neydi kabartma tozuydu yemek
sodasının diğer ismi mesela Mela
kabartma tozu O da bilinmekte nahco3
nahco3 derim ben buna bir de Çamaşır
sodası vardı na2 co3 dediğimiz
bileşikler bunlar bunlar da bazik
maddelerdir Şimdi şunu söyleyeyim soda
ifadesi kafanı karıştırmasın yabancılar
soda dediğinde Maden suyunu kastediyor
ama bizde mesela soda işte Çamaşır
sodası veya işte yemek sodası Bunlar
bazik maddeler ama maden suyu dediğimiz
şey asidik bir madde deterjan işte
genellikle işte nedir bazik bir yapıya
sahiptir sabunlar bazik bir yapıya
sahiptir Burada da örneklerini vermiş Öz
özelliklerini söylersek işte bazlar ne
yapar işte tatları acıdır sulu çözeltisi
cilde kayganlık hissi oluşturmakta böyle
aldığında kayganlık hissi oluştursa
bazik olduğunu anlayabiliriz başka suda
az ya da çok
iyonlaştırıcı iletir diyoruz kırmızı
turnus solu maviye çevirir mavi turnus
sonsa rengini değiştirmez ifadesini
kullanıyoruz aşındırıcı etkiye sahiptir
Bunlar da aynı şekilde cilde temasında
tahriş edici yakıcı etki vardır Bunlarda
da ve Asitlerle tepkimeye girerek tuz
oluşturur neydi asitler bazlarla
tepkimeye girerek tuz oluşturuyor bazlar
da Asitlerle tepkimeye girerek tuz
oluşturacak ve amfoter metallerle
tepkimeye girerek Hidrojen gazı
oluşturabilir ama diğer metallerle
tepkimeye girmiyorlar bunun da detayları
ileride verileceği için burada Yüzeysel
olarak söylüyorum kimdir bu amfoter
metaller işte burada da yazıyor sana
aldığım pabuçları çarık zannetme B
şeklinde kodladığı bir şeydir Bunun
dediğim gibi detayları ileride burada
Yüzeysel olarak söyleyip geçiyorum suya
Oh veren maddelere Biz baz Diyoruz ki
genellikle şöyledir formüllerde oh biter
naoh koh boh 2 işte mgoh2 gibi nh3
burada zıt olandır işte hidrojen olup da
baz olan nh3 nh3 şöyle kodla
amonyaktan kazdır ya da amonyak bazdır
bilmeyen kazdır bak suya ne veriyor Oh
veriyor suya Oh verenler baz suya H
verenler asit olarak birazdan
söyleyeceğim ki metallerin oksitleri de
bazik karakterlidir bu odun külünde de
metal oksitler bulunmakta O yüzden
baziktir Mesela bu zaten Metal oksitleri
atarsan da ortama yine ne verecektir Oh
verecek yine dediğim gibi bak yüzeysel
geçiyorum detaylı bilmek zorunda
değilsin çünkü map kitabında bu detaylar
yok Ben şu anda ek bilgi veriyorum sana
asit is suya ne veriyordu h3o ya da h+
iyonu veriyordu suya attık h3o iyonu
veren maddelere asit Diyoruz ki işte H2
so4 hcl başka H3 po4 hbr HF hcn hno3
gibi Ama bak burada ohla bitip de
ch3cooh asittir sirke asidi bunu da ek
olarak söylemiş olalım Bir de şu vardı
bak 8 sınıf müfredatında da görmüştün
şöyle bir bilgi vardı Asit yağmurları
Asit yağmurları ne sebep oluyordu
karbondioksit diyorduk kükürt dioksit
kükürt trioksit Yani şöyle CO2 CO2 co3
Bir de ne vardı no2 gazları vardı Bunlar
atmosferdeki su ile birleşip asit
yağmuruna sebep oluyordu Demek ki
bunlara ne diyoruz biz asidik oksitler
diyoruz ametalle oksijenin birleşmesi
sonucunda oluşan maddelerdir Bunlar
fazla oksijen birleşiyor CO2 Ne oldu
işte suya asit bak hidrojen iyonu verdi
n25 aynı şekilde hidrojen ver verdi CO2
aynı şekilde hidrojen verdi bunlara da
asidik oksit diyoruz Asit yağmuru
örneğidir Aslında Bu yazdıkları şimdi
gel bakalım bu örneklerde ne diyor
bazların sulu çözeltileri ile ilgili
hangisi yanlıştır neydi bazların tadı
acıydı ekşidir diyor Hayır canım bu
neydi aside ait bir özelliktir yanlışı
bulduk ama devam edelim cilde kayganlık
hissi oluşturur Evet bazların böyle bir
özelliği vardı bulundukları maddelere ne
acılık katar Evet neydi acı maddeler
zaten a doğruysa C yanlış C doğruysa a
yanlıştı değil mi Başka Asitlerle
tepkimeye girer tuz oluştururlar doğru
ve sulu çözeltileri elektrolit yani
elektriği iletmekte ydi Doğrudur biz
yanlışı aradığımız için cevabımız ne
oldu a seçeneği oldu Burada ne diyor
Asitlerin sulu çözeltileri ile ilgili
hangileri doğrudur diyor Bakalım
elektrik akımını iletir Evet az ya da
çok elektrik akımını iletir diyorduk
mavi turunun solu kırmızıya çevirir
asitler kırmızıya bazlar maviye
çeviriyordu Doğrudur aşındırıcı yakıcı
etkiye sahiptir Bu zaten asit ve baz
için ortak bir özellikte cevap Ne oldu 1
2 3 e seçeneği oldu burada da diyor ki
asit ve bazlar için ortak özelliktir
diyor Evet sulu çözeltilerin elektrik
akımını ilit mesi ortak özellikli doğru
aktif metallerle tepkimeye girme bu
asitler için geçerli bazlar için değildi
gitti nötrleşme tepkimesi Evet asitler
bazla bazla asitle nötrleşme tepkimesi
verebilir Doğrudur O zaman cevap 1 ve 3
olacaktır yani C seçeneği Şimdi şöyle
bir şey var günlük hayatta bazı maddeler
var ki İşte bunların asit mi baz mı
olduğunu anlamak için bir yöntem daha
var mesela yapmışsındır Belki çay var
çaya limon sıktığında çayın rengi böyle
sarıya doğru dönüyor sen orada
zannediyorsun ki limondan kaynaklanıyor
limon sıktım ya limon sarı O yüzden o
sarardı Hayır dostum asidik ortamda çay
sarı renk almakta Mesela şunu da
deneyebilirsin evde yap bunu Bak çok
güzel bir deneydir Çayı doldur ama böyle
şey olsun çok koyu yap hafif açık renkli
yap yani açık renkli derken yani tavşan
kanının biraz açığını yap yani buna
Mesela İki bardağı doldur birine limon
sık renginin açılmasını gör diğerine de
şey bu kabartma tozu dök kabartma tozu
döktüğünde orada da rengin koyulaştığını
göreceksin Çünkü bazik ortamda çay koyu
renk olur asidik ortamda İsa açık renk
olur mesela Ha Burada o zaman çay ne
görevi gördü asit ve bazı anlamamı
sağladı değil mi veya turnusol kağıdı
aynı mantıkla turnusol kağıdı ne yapıyor
asidik ortamda kırmızı renk alıyor bazik
ortamda mavi renk alıyor bana asit ve
bazı tanıtmış oluyor yani tadına
bakamadığım asit ve bazları buradan
anlayabilir miyim Çok da rahat bir
şekilde anlarım mesela günlük hayatta
daha çok örneği var mesela Üzüm suyu da
aynı şekilde bir etkiye sahiptir veya bu
mor lahana var ya kırmızı lahana diye
geçer mor lahana mor lahanaya mesela
limon sıktığında kırmızıya döner rengi
bazik bir şey eklediğinde ise yeşile
döner rengi ve hatta Burada da
gösteriyor bak Görüyor musun bu mesela
bazik bir şeymiş Demek ki Şuradaki de
asidik bir şey şu ortadaki de nötr işte
asitten baza Bu renk değişimini gösteren
bir maddedir Ha kırmızı lahana ya da
işte mor lahana dediğimiz ismiyle ne
yapıyormuş asidik ve bazik ortamda
farklı renk alarak içine koyduğumuz
maddenin hangi özellikte olduğunu
anlamamızı sağlıyormuş ki bunlara biz
işte indikatör ya da belirteç diyoruz
yine bunu 8 sınıfta kısmen görmüştün
Tabii indikatörler çeşit çeşit doğal
indikatör dedik işte çay mor lahana
Başka ne var vardı işte üzüm dedik Değil
mi Bunlar gül yaprağı Bunlar mesela
doğal indikatörler yapay lsa işte Fenol
fitalin var başka ne var işte Metil
oranj gibi sentetik olanlar da mevcut
Bak burada turnus Solan bahsediyor
turnusol işte kırmızı turnusolu baza
daldırdı Ne oldu maviye döndü işte mavi
turnusolu aside daldırdı ne oldu
kırmızıya döndü işte asidik ve bazik
ortamda farklı renk alıyor Bir de
bunları işte hepsini birlikte yaptı bir
şey var ki onu yakından göstereceğim dur
dostum da dur Heh neredeydi burada Bak
şöyle göstereyim sana bu L heh zoomlıon
görüyor musun Bu ne biliyor musun pH
kağıdı dediğimiz şey bu pH kağıdı asidik
ve bazik ortamda farklı renk alan e
durumlar var üzerinde indikatörler var
işte farklı renk alıyorlar Buna göre ne
yapıyorlar ortamın ph'ını belirliyorlar
mesela Hatta şunu şu an size hemen bir
deney göstermek istiyorum şöyle yapalım
sirkemi aldım şöyle sirkemde bir miktar
suya döktüm Şu Suya döktüm onu şimdi
göstereceğim Bak şimdi şimdi bu su çok
ekşi lan Öf Heh Neyse bu şu anda asidik
bir ortam Acaba şu an kaç PH'ı kaç onu
bir hesaplayalım istersen Bak aldım
bunlardan bir tane bu çubuklardan içine
daldırdım bekletiyorum birazcık
beklettim Hah renkler birazcık değişti
lan mikrofona vurdum Ha dur şimdi burada
renklerini kıyaslayacak Bak şöyle
kıyaslıyorum nereye geldiğine bakıyorum
Aha yanına koyarak göstereceğim Bak
yaklaştıracak şimdi Aşağı yukarı burada
şöyle yanına koyarak gösteriyorum bak
zoomla lan Bak Hah gördün mü neymiş şu
an pH'ı 3 olan bir çözelti elde ettim
ben bur buradan bunu anlamış oldum işte
bu pH kağıdı dediğimiz şey içerisinde
farklı pH renkleri daha doğrusu farklı
ortamlarda renk değiştiren maddeler
emdirilmiş bir kağıt bu pH kağıdı
diyoruz buna maddenin hangi phl olduğunu
asidik mi bazik mi olduğunu anlamamızı
sağlıyor yok şu an içmeyeceğim bunu
Bunlar tek kullanımlık Tabii bir kere
kullandım Hani bir daha başka yerde
kullanım yok Bitti onun işte ona
atacağım Mesela sizin için kullanırım Ne
olacak sanki Bak burada da mesela
gösteriyor işte
daldırmak Ne olmuş işte renklerini
belirliyor demek ki pH'ı 8' miş 7y demiş
Neyse artık buradan belirliyor şimdi pH
kavramını görmüştün basit bir şekilde
anlatılmıştı 8 sınıfta bir daha
hatırlatıyorum neydi pH dediğimiz durum
7'den küçükse asidik ortam içindir 7'den
büyükse bazik ortamdır Neydi bu oda
sıcaklığında bahsettiğimiz durum Peki pH
ne demek Power hidrojen Power of the
hidrojen ya da hidrojen gücü gibi ifade
edilmekte 7'den küçük olduğu ortamlara
asit çözeltisinin 25 derecede 7'den
büyük olduğu ortamlar İsa bazik çözelti
olduğunu ifade etmekte Şimdi şöyle
düşünürsek Bak şuraya bir çizgi
çiziyorum 0 dedim Şuraya da 14 dedim
Şuraya da 0 ne yok 7 dedim Bak şöyle bu
tarafa doğru gidece asitlik artar şu
tarafa doğru gittikçe de bazlık artar He
o zaman pH azalıyorsa asitlik artıyordu
pH küçüldükçe asitlik artar bazlık
azalır başka pH büyüyorsa da asitlik
azalır bazlık artar ifadesini ne
yapabiliriz kullanabiliriz işte skal mız
da burada bak aşağıda da gösteriyor Tam
ph'ın 7 olduğu durum 25 derecede nötr
çözeltiyi ifade ediyor ııa doğru
gittikçe asitlik artıyor 14'e doğru
gittikçe de bazlık artıyor ifadesini
kullanıyoruz işte en çok kullanılan bazı
asitler bazlar var burada bak akü asidi
çok asidik görüyor musun Sıfıra yakın
burada mide asidi var ph1 1,5 arası çok
asidik limon mesela aynı şekilde başka
ne var sirkeyi de Bu üçünü olduğu
yerlere koyabiliriz soda demiş yani
maden suyundan bahsediyor soda derken
aslında şöyle yapalım şuna maden
suyundan bahsediyor başka domates mesela
asidiktir hafif ekşiliği vardır kahve
hocam O nasıl asidik asidik dostum onu
böyle zor anlarsın ama asidiktir Hatta
ph'ını ölçebiliriz İlerleyen zamanlarda
onu da yapayım ben bir süt mesela yine
laktik asitten dolayı asidik bir madde
Saf su zaten nötr kan çok az baziktir 8
civarı yumurta akı kayganlık hissi değil
mi bazik bir madde antiasit bak mide
asit O zaman antiasit ne olmalı baz
olmalı Değil mi buradan bunu
anlayabiliriz amonyak bazdır bilmeyen
kazdır söylemiştik sabun yine bazik
görüyorsun çamaşır suyu lavabo açıcı
Bunlar da bazı önemli bazik maddeler
şimdi gel bu sorulara Bakalım burada ne
diyor sorumuz da bana bazı yerler vermiş
x k y z t diye yerler vermiş diyor ki
hangisindeki gibi olamaz Şimdi x k ve y
asit Eyvallah Z ve T ise baz Şimdi x
asit olması gerekiyorsa çamaşır suyu
bazdır O zaman bu yanlış yerde bunu
kafadan eledik ama devam edelim y
domates suyu olabilir mi asidik bir
madde olabilir z ne bazik bir madde kan
çok az baziktir söylemiştik olabilir
Deterjanlı su baziktir ki zaten T de
bazik Gördüğün gibi 7'in üstünde
olabilir K ise burada He başka ymiş bu
üstteki domates suyu Neyse Ha buradaki
k'ye bakarsak da K ne olacaktır asidik
bir madde limon suyu Olabilir mi
Olabilir Biz yanlışı bulduk cevabımız a
seçeneği Burada ne diyor Diyor ki
Aşağıdaki maddelerden hangisinin asidik
bazik karakteri yanlış verilmiştir
deterjan bazik de doğru diş macunu diş
macunu şeydeki Dişlerdeki asitliği
gidermek için kullanılıyordu o zaman
bazik olması lazım asidik demiş yanlış
yoğurt sütten elde ediliyor süt asidik
is O zaman bu da birazcık asidik olmalı
o zaman olur lavabo açıcı bazik de hatta
bak yan tarafta gözüküyor Doğrudur mide
suyu mide asidik bir ortamdı Bu da
Doğrudur biz yanlışı bulduk cevap B
seçeneği şimdi şu var derişe seyrelme
diye bir şey var ki bir sulu çözeltiye
su ilave edersen seyrelir yani oradaki
madde oranı azalır çözünen madde oranı
azalır bir sulu çözeltideki suyu
buharlaştırıcı da ne oluyor biliyor
musun bu durumda da Derişim artıyor yani
madde çözünen madde oranı artmış oluyor
Bunu Mesela şöyle örneklendir bilil
diyelim Ne olsun şekerli bir Çayın var
Çok şekerli Ne yapman lazım birazcık
dökersin üzerine su eklediğinde o şeker
oranını Azal mış olursun değil mi Bak
seyreltmek var tadı az geldi böyle şey
yapıyorsun Bir şerbet yapılıyor
karıştırdın yeterince tatlı olmadığını
düşünün suyunu buharlaştırır ne olur bu
sefer de tatlılığı artar değil mi şerbet
yaparken suyunu buharlaştırarak
derişimini arttırırlar günlük hayattan
örnek olarak vermiş oldum işte burada da
onu söylüyor bak bir Asit çözeltisi var
diyelim su ilavesi yaparsam gel bunu
burada deneyle yapalım ya niye böyle
söylüyoruz ki dur bak Aha bu benim özel
bir pH metem şimdi bu asidik bir ortamdı
şöyle bunun ph'ını hemen ölçeceğim bir
dakika
nerede lan kaçırdım Heh şimdi ph'ını
ölçüyorum içine daldırdım aha şöyle
Hatta yaklaştıracak Dur bakayım Görüldü
mü He 3.50 civarı bir şey şu anda bak ne
yapacağım su ilavesi yapacağım Saf su
ilavesi şöyle çıkartım Oh saf suyunu
ilave ettim su ilavesi yapınca ne olması
lazım asitliğin azalması lazım değil mi
Derişim azaldı asitlik azalıyorsa o
zaman ph'ın artması lazım Hemen bir daha
ölçüyorum Aha şimdi bir daha bakalım
şöyle dur ekranı parlat He şöyle bak bir
daha bak lan netle beni görme l beni gör
ha gördün mü bak ne oldu 38'e çıktı su
ilavesiyle işte su ilavesi
seyreltmenin ph'ını ne yaptı yukarıya
taşıdı dostum Peki aynı durumu şöyle
yapsaydım bazik bir ortam için
düşünseydim Dur bakalım bazik bir ortam
burada benim çamaşır suyum var Bak
şurada bir çamaşır suyu var şöyle kokusu
iğrenç buna Mesela pH metreyi
daldırıp göstereyim şöyle 10 civarı bir
pha sahip çamaşır suyu şimdi bu bazik
bir madde şimdi buna su katarsak ne
olacak hemen şöyle suyunu ilave edelim
He bu da ul bayağı ilave etmişim ha
döktüm şey yaptım bir şeyler yaptım Bak
bu da 8 civarına düştü Neyse şimdi net
diyemedim 8 civarına düşürdüm bayağı bir
şey eklemişim Demek ki yani biraz şey de
var altta Ekstradan bir tane de şey
koydum e leğen koydum fazlasını oraya
döküyorum o şekilde seyrelti Burada da 8
küsur geldi mesela bayağı bir
buradan bir şey anlamış olduk demek ki
asidik bir çözeltiye su ilavesi yaparsak
asitlik azalacağı için pH artacak bazik
bir çözeltiye su ilavesi yaparsak bazlık
azalacaktır bu durumda da pH azalacaktır
Dostum şimdi şu aklına takıl hocam nasıl
oluyor ya Bak şöyle düşün asidik bir
çözelti PH'ı kaç olsun 3 olsun 3 su
ilave ediyorum suyun PH'ı kaç 7 7 3 daha
kaç etti 10 böl 2'ye 5 bak 3'tü 5'e
çıktı Anladın mı demek istediğimi yani
pH arttı asidik bir çözeltiye su ilave
ed Ersen pH arttı Şimdi başka bir örnek
bazik bir çözelti bazik çözeltinin PH'ı
kaç olsun 11 olsun 11 su ilave ettim
suyuni 7 7 11 Daha 18 bö 2'ye 9 bak
11'de 9A Ne oldu pH azalmış oldu yani
bazik bir çözeltiye su ilavesi yaparsak
pH azalıyor Çünkü 7'ye yaklaşıyor öyle
düşün asidik bir çözeltiye su ilavesi
yaptığımızda İsa yine 7'ye yaklaşıyor bu
durumda da pH artmış oluyor tamam mı
dostum Peki tam tersi su buharlaştırır
ne olur asit çözeltisinde mesela su
buharlaştırır ne olur suyu buharla
kırdığında Derişim arttı e Derişim
artınca asitlik arttı asitlik artınca da
ne oluyordu sıfıra doğru yaklaşmıyor
muydu yani pH azalıyordu He Demek ki su
ilavesinde asit çözeltisinde pH Artıyor
Su buharlaştırır Sak pH azalıyor basik
çözeltiye geldim su buharlaştırıcı
Derişim arttı yani bazlık arttı bazlık
artıyorsa 14'e doğru gidecek yani pH
artacak He geldik o zaman ne diyoruz su
buharlaştırıp artar su ilavesinde ise pH
azalır diyoruz tamam mı dostum Şimdi
bunu niye yaptım biliyor musun dostum
şunun için yaptım bu etkinliği doldurmak
için Milli Eğitim kitabında da var böyle
bir etkinlik sirkeli su sirkeli suyun ph
değeri asidik olduğu için nedir 7'den
küçüktür çok güzel şunun yanına İstersen
yazalım asit diye belirtelim çamaşır
suyu neydi baziki pH 10 civarında
bulmuştuk değil mi Şunun yanına da bazik
ekledik bazik ise phı 7'den büyüktü
Sabunlu su Sabunlu su da bazik Bir
maddeyi yanına yapıştırdık karbonatlı
neydi bazik maddelerde yapıştırdık tuz
ruhunun asidik olduğunu söylemiştik diş
macunu neydi diş macunu e bazik Bir
maddeyi zaten phan da anlayabiliriz
Gazlı içecekler asitli içecek diye
geçiyor değil mi asit zaten bak asit pH
7'den küçük baz 7'den büyük baz 7'den
büyük Bu da 7'den büyük asit küçük baz
büyük asit 7'den küçük su ilavesi
Sonrasında ne oluyordu su ilavesi aside
su ilavesi yaparsam asitliği azalmalı o
zaman pH'ı ne olmalı artmalı Değil mi
dostum Çamaşır suyu baziki bazik bir
çözelti su ilavesi yaptım bazlık
azalması lazım Derişim azalıyor bazlık
azalıyorsa pH ne olacaktır azalacaktır
yazalım azalır güzel Sabunlu su su
ilavesi azalır zaten bazlarda su
ilavesinde pH azalıyordu 7'ye
yaklaşıyordu tuz ruhu asidik bir madde
aside su ilavesi yaparsak asitlik
azalmalı o zaman 7'ye Doğru yaklaşmalı
artmalı değil mi artar diye belirttik e
diş macunu neydi azalır demiştik asidik
madde gazlı içecekte de ne olacaktır
artar şeklinde yorumlarız bakalım
buradaki sorularda ne diyor Tablodaki
maddelerden hangileri ne diyor asidik ve
bazik olanları yazınız diyor şöyle
yapalım Bak şuraya asidik yi yazalım
asidik Şuraya da baziki yazalım bazik
asidik olanlar neydi 1 vardı Başka ne
vardı 5 vardı bir de 7 vardı bazik
olanlar neydi 2 3 4 ve 6'yı değil mi
böyle belirtebiliriz diyor ki Saf su
ilavesiyle hangilerinin pH değeri
artmıştır pH değeri artanlar asidik
olanlardı yani 1 vardı 5 vardı bir de 7
vardı burada diyor ki limon tuzu ve
sirke kireç giderici olarak
kullanılabilir mi Evet kireç baziki
kireç bazik olduğu için asidik
maddelerle giderilebilir yani limon tuzu
ve sirke Neydi o zaman kireci
giderebilir kullanılabilir mi Evet
kullanılır Evet kullanılır sebepse
asidik madde değil mi asidik madde baz
ile tepkime verir Böyle belirtebiliriz
Bir de diyor ki diş fırçasına kuru
haldeyken diş macunu sürülmesinin nedeni
nedir Eğer diş macunu ıslatılırsa ne
gibi etkisi olur şimdi kuru halde
kullandığında bazik bir maddeden
bahsediyor zaten amacımız bazik bir
ortama oluşturmak değil mi su ilavesi ne
yapıyordu bazik bir maddenin ph'ını
azaltıyorsa
de zaten kaygan bir madde ıslattım e
çabucak akıp gidecek çok da uygun bir
yöntem değil Bunu söylemek istiyor işte
diyor ki mutfak malzemelerinde oluşan
pasları temizlemek için kola
kullanılabilir mi paslar bazik
maddelerdir metal oksitler metal
oksitler bazik demiştik O yüzden orayı
verdim işte Hoca burayı niye verd A
bunun için verdim işte metal oksitler
bazik e kola da asidik o zaman kolayla
temizleyebilir miyiz Evet
temizleyebiliriz bunu Bak buradan
söyleyebiliriz dostum Peki kola yerine
ne kullanabilirsin kireç çözücüler var
bu fosforik asit falan içeren maddeler
karbonik asit içerenler olabilir veya
tuz ruhu olabilir evde yine kullanılan
kimyasallardan bir tanesi asidik olduğu
için yine pası ne yapabilir giderebilir
yani Kimyayı bildiğinde ne yapmış oldun
bak Mutfaktaki yağı kiri pası şunu bunu
kiracı giderebilir bak Önemli bir şey
çok güzel şeylerden bahsettik aslında
bir de önemli bir şeyden bahsedeceğim Bu
da alüminyum diye bir şey vardır
alüminyum mutfaklarda bolca
kullandığımız maddelerden bir tanesi
normalde biliyorsun işte alüminyum
Birçok yerde vardır alüminyum doğrama
vardır yani cam pencere kaplamalarında
falan da kullanılmakta ama evde
kullandığımız bir yer var ne bu
alüminyum folyo olarak yani gıdalarda
fırın yemekleri yaparken işte ısının
homojen olarak dağılmasında neyi
kullanıyoruz Bu alüminyum folyoyu
kullanıyoruz başka alüminyum ambalaj
kapları vardır ki alüminyum ambalaj
kaplarıyla kapattığında işte şeyden nem
ısı ışık bu etkilerden koruruz ve
gıdanın daha uzun ömürlü olmasını
sağlayabiliriz Peki başka nerede
kullanılıyor Mesela yazın arabaların ön
camlarında böyle bir parlak bir şey
görürsün Böyle katman kat Mandır en ön
kısmı alüminyumdan Neden bunu
kullanıyorlar ışığı yansıtsın diye
arabanın içi ısınmasın diye Onu
koymadığın da arabanın içi hamama
dönüyor mesela Hatta böyle çocuk falan
unutanlar oluyor ya işte camı kırıyorlar
bir şey yapıyorlar sebebi o işte İçerisi
aşırı sıcak oluyor fırın gibi oluyor
yani işte onu koyarak ne yapıyorlar
engellemiş oluyorlar ışığı yansıtarak
veya evlerde kışın şeylerin bu kalorifer
peteklerinin arkasına şey koyarlar bir
tane böyle alüminyum levha koyarlar o
levha ısı ve ışığı yansıtarak ısının
Odaya tekrar gelmesini sağlıyor Mesela
bak Birçok yerde ısı tasarrufu için Bunu
kullanırlar şimdi bu alüminyum folyo
evlerde kullanılan bir şey demiştik
değil mi Dur bak dah yanımda var Hoca
Yok artık daha neler diyebilirsin de
şöyle yakından göstereceğim Bak şu
tarafı daha mat olan şu tarafı daha
parlak olan bir şeydir Hocam niye bunun
bir tarafı mat bir tarafı parlak Yani
bunun bir amacı mı var Evet kesinlikle
bir amacı var Bu arada mutfakta Ne var
ne yok odaya doldurdum şu anda var ya
sağlam fırça yiyeceğim Hanım beni
korursunuz değil mi Aşağıda yorumlara
yazın yenge hocamıza zarar verme diye
yani beni korursunuz diye düşünüyorum
Neyse ben bunları mutfağa tekrar
bırakacağım şimdi bak bu alüminyum
folyonun mat ve parlak kısmı nasıl
kullanılıyor şöyle söyleyeyim sana Eee
yemek pişireceksin yani sıcaklık lazım
değil mi yemeği sararken parlak tarafı
yemeğe doğru gelecek şekilde sardığında
olay şudur mat tarafı ısıyı tutan bir
yapıya sahip parlak tarafı da ısı ısıyı
yansıtan bir yapıya ışı ışık ve ısıyı
yansıtan bir yapıya sahip şimdi parlak
tarafını yemeğe doğru çevirdiğinde dışı
da mat olduğunda dışarıdan ısı geldi
tuttu içeriye gönderdi içeride yemek
pişerken ısındı ya dışarıya yansıtmak
isteyecek ama alüminyum folyonun parlak
tarafı orada tekrar yemeğe yansıtacak Bu
da yemeğin pişme süresini kısaltacak Çok
etkili bir yöntemdir bunu söylemiş
olayım Eğer soğuksa yiyeceğimiz soğuk
durmasını istiyorsak bu durumda da tam
tersi mat tarafını yiyecek tarafına
koyuyorsun parlak tarafını dışarıya
veriyorsun e parlak taraf dışarıdan ısı
gelmek isteğinde yansıtacak içerideki de
ne yapacak tutacak Böylelikle soğuk
kalacak mesela Ama tabii ki evlerde bunu
kullanıyoruz da şöyle bir tehlikesi var
dostum Bak onu söyleyeyim sana bu
alüminyum folyoyu kullandığımızda bazen
doğrudan yemeği içine doldurup böyle
sarıp sarmalayıp fırına veriyoruz
Aslında yemekle temasından kaçınmak
fayda var yani Mümkünse bir yağlı
kağıtla kaplayıp sonrasında alüminyum
folyoyla sarmak lazım hocam Ne alaka
Niye böyle bir şey yapalım diyorsan
sebebi şu Çünkü bu alüminyum folyonun
yemekte çözünme ihtimali var Nasıl ya
hocam bak Ah sana burada bir etkinlik
yapılmış bir etkinlik Bak şöyle
yaklaştırdı Bazen bu gıdaları mesela et
marinasyon yap pH'ı al 6.12 olan bir
Marine sistemi var Marine yaptım bununla
6.12 bununla yemeği işte koydum ne
yapsın pişirdim veya işte bu sıcaklık
belli bir sıcaklıkta yaptın sonra
Yemekteki alüminyum miktarına bakıyorsun
0.047 miligramlık bir alüminum tespit
edilmiş 100 gr içerisinde sonra bak 6.07
olduğunda İsa
0.058 çıkmış Allah Allah ne değişti Bak
6.12 şöyle pH skalasını çiziyorum şurası
7 şurası 6.12
ş şurası da 6.07 Ha 6.07 daha asidik He
Demek ki bu yemeğin marinasyonunda
asitlik oranı artınca çözünen alüminyum
miktarı artmış oldu Vay anasını bak çok
önemli bir şey görmüş olduk mesela
sıcaklığın etkisi var mı Bak o da var
100 derecede yaptığında 0,48 miligram
birikiyor Ken bu 1ci marinasyon var ya
6.12 ile 250 dereceye getirdi ise 0,06
2'ye çıkıyor He miktar arttı gördün mü
Demek ki Sıcaklık artınca tepkime hız
hızlandı tepkime hızlandığı için de
çözünen alüminyum miktarını arttırmış
oldu bunu söyleyebiliriz burada Mesela
ikinci marinasyonda zaten asidik ortam
var Fazla çözüyordu E bir de şey yaptık
sıcaklığı arttırdık daha fazla madde
çözmüş oldu Gördün mü He o zaman şu
sorulara bakalım Diyor ki sosun pH
değerinin azalması ne anlama gelir E
asitlik artar asitlik arttığı için de
çözünen alüminyum oranını arttırır bu
durum ve sıcaklık artışı ile beraber
alüminyum miktarındaki artışın ne anlama
geldiğini soruyor sıcaklık artışı
tepkime hızlanıyor haliyle daha fazla
alüminyum çözünebilir hale gelmiş oluyor
Bunu yazmadım söylüyorum diyor ki
yiyeceğin alüminyum geçişini azaltmak
için ne yapmak lazım yiyeceğe alüminyum
geçişini azaltmak için mat yüzeyin
tepkimeye girme oranı daha düşük oluyor
genellikle Bundan dolayı mat yüzeyi
kullanmak daha mantıklı Evet o zaman da
daha yavaş pişiyor ama yani etki midir
kullanılabilir öyle söyleyeyim ama en
güzeli en doğrusu Bence önce bir yağlı
kağıtla kaplayıp sonrasında alüminyum
folyoyu kullanmak daha etkili olacaktır
onu da söyleyeyim doğrudan temas
etmemekte fayda var Bak görüyor musun
Kimya ne kadar etkiliymiş yediğimiz
gıdaya kadar nasıl olduğunu da görmüş
olduk işte Evet dostum İstersen bir ara
verelim bundan sonra diğer kısımda
kimyanın alt dallarından şundan bundan
bahsedeceğiz bir sonraki dersimizde
bunlardan bahsedeceğiz bak bak bugün
seninle ne yapmış olduk deney yapmış
olduk başka işte günlük hayatta asitler
bazlar kimya nerelerde kullanılıyor
Aslında bunlardan bahsetmiş olduk Çok da
böyle detaylı şeylerden bahsetmeye
çalıştım çok kullandığımız şeyler var
Bak işte bu marinasyon çok çok
yaptığımız bir şeydir evde marinasyon
deyince hocam nasıl oluyor ya soslamak
ya yemeği soslamak Tan bahsediyorum Ne
yapıyorsun işte portakallı ördek
portakal bak ne oluyor asidik bir şey
koymuş oluyorsun onu da alüminyum şeyle
sardın ha bak portakal portakal burada
portakal asidik mi bazik mi Bunu da
merak ediyor olabilirsin hemen şöyle
geldim aha böyle kesiyorum bıçağımla
daya yiyeceğim bari iyice şey yapayım
Paşa ediyim ortalığı bak kestim
portakalım Burada şimdi bu acaba asidik
mi değil mi Bunu anlamaya çalışıyoruz
hemen şuraya şöyle portakalım da
yerleştirdim Bir tane de bardak
getireyim şöyle dur L bastıracağım H
bastırdım Oh mis Allah o pis dayak var
var ya Fight var Akşama şöyle yapalım
şunu aldık nereye koyacağım lan bunu şur
bak bu asidik mi değil mi Bunu anlamak
istiyorum şöyle açalım hemen daldırdım
vallahi güzel asidikmi ş Ya bak şş He
bak 383 gibi bir şey çıktı mesela pH'ı
güzel asidik olduğunu anlamış olduk işte
marinasyonda portakallı ördekte bunu
kullandın ya E bunu kullanınca Ne oldu
işte alüminyumun çözünme oranını
arttırmış oldun işte o demin gösterdiğim
şey bununla alakalıydı Evet ara
vereceğimizi söylemiştik Ben buraları
toplayacağım biliyorsun sağlam fırça
yiyeceğim Çünkü şu an var ya haşat
durumda Burası leğenler sular şunlar
bunlar bunların hepsini toplamam lazım
sonraki dersimizde kaldığımız yerden
devam edeceğiz iki fosfor bir asit kimya
Bu kadar basit diyoruz görüşmek
üzere l